you know it is said that you are the sum
of the people you spend your time with
so if you're interested at all in
cultivating your
character you want to be judicious about
the people you spend your time with
because you
functionally sort of again become the
sum of the people you spend your time
with so i think about this a lot
what makes me decide
that i like someone how do i choose who
to spend
my time with what are the
characteristics that i look for
in my friends you know my compatriots my
com companions
right the people that i that i that i
sort of
whose company i enjoy my companions it's
a good word
um companions is a good word but in any
case
are there characteristics that we should
keep in mind when
curating our friends when selecting our
friends i mean it's a it's an important
investment you know
uh an important choice and so what
occurred to me today
is that what you're looking for is for a
fundamental
um quality of character
that you have resonance with this idea
of resonance is very important and so
how do you determine if you have
resonance with someone
well pay attention to what they notice
and this is what i've decided ultimately
then
the people who i like are the people
for whom what are people
uh who notice things that land for me
the people who i like are people who
notice things
that i enjoy right i i enjoy
seeing the things they notice because
think about it when you hang out with
someone
you know they're going to point out
things in any situation that unfolds
you can notice a million things about
any situation and certain people will
notice certain things so
you go with a friend in nature and the
things he notices in the environment
and the insights that it leads to and
the reflections
that he offers and the responses that he
might give to
something that you share if all of those
things that he happens
to think of that he happens to notice or
things that resonate that land for you
that's a sign that you have congruence
with this person that's
a friend right
somebody who notices things that you
have resonance with
and that's a much better indicator of a
good friend to pick
than somebody you get along with or
somebody you have things in common with
or somebody that's
nice oh they're nice do you like this
guy yeah he's nice you like this girl
yeah she's nice we get along you know
she's nice we get along no
man your friends should be people who
notice
things that you enjoy that's because
you don't see the world as it is you see
the world as you are and they
too they don't see the world as it is
they see the world as they are
for as a man is so he sees said blake
and so
in other words the things they see the
things they notice
mirror their essential nature they
mirror it mirrors who they are
and so if you like what they notice it
means you have resonance with their
fundamental nature which means you and
that person's character
are in a beautiful congruence there's
harmony there there is
affinity there so again i'll end this
thought
because it's very important and you have
to choose your friends wisely
in this world choose people
who notice things in the world who point
out things in the environment when you
guys hang out who
who share insights whenever you guys are
together that you enjoy that land for
you
that's a sign that that's a person that
needs to be your friend that's
that's your friend because it is
enriching
because it is enriching it just expands
your world
and and it is enriching um
yes it is enriching because your world
is expanded in ways that you enjoy
your world is expanded in ways that are
inviting to you
that resonate with you that that that
for whom the invitation to expand your
world is one that was
useless to resist because you loved
every minute of it
right because you can also hang out with
people who notice things in the world
that don't resonate with you
they point out things in the world that
cause you distress you don't want to
hang out with that person
because they may be expanding your world
but they're expanding it in directions
you
want to go to yeah you know they're
expanding your world in ways you're not
interested in expanding it you know like
it's okay to be
curatorial and discerning man all music
enhances your
auditory and emotional experience but
some music takes you to a really dark
place and some takes you to beautiful
places
and sometimes you might want to go to
the dark places but for the most part
the choices you make
should be for those things that enlarge
your world in a way
that points towards the beautiful yeah
no we are we are here to
drive darkness away with our light you
know exactly
we are here to drive darkness away with
our light and so again
the people you like the people you spend
weird time with people you choose as
friends should be people who notice
things
in the world that you enjoy that you
find resonance with that every time you
hang out with them it's like wow
what a delight to notice what you notice
to notice what this person notices
right that should be why you have
resonance with this video if you
resonate with my work
it should be because you enjoy seeing
what i see
you enjoy the things i point out you
enjoy
noticing what i notice that's resonance
that's congruence
that's how you choose a friend
beautifully said
thanks man thanks for noticing
[Music]
[Laughter]
thanks for noticing that's wow you and
your beautiful puns thank you brother